to me it's less about technology than
about money I think that people fell in
love with money about 30 years ago and
there was a lot more money I mean that's
what everyone forgets there was also a
didn't just fall in love with it because
they were weak or wicked or indeed they
didn't fall in love with a period
because they were weak or wicked indeed
I don't think people are just as I don't
think people are any smarter today than
they were 200 years ago I don't think
they're any more vile today than they
were 200 years ago so but what I think
happened was the potential for lots of
people to make money doing things that
in the past you couldn't make money
doing was profoundly corrupting and so
if you like a kind of Hollywood ization
of spirit took place so that people
wanted to do things that were
money-making my mother liked living well
but her idea wasn't to that that what
she would do would make a lot of money
and there were even economic you know
when people of my mother's generation
came to New York say in the 50s the end
of the 50s in her case but this was true
from the 1920s through the end of the
1970s I think you could live honorably
that is to say you could have your own
apartment it was a decent apartment in a
decent neighborhood for not a lot of
money you know since the 1980s in order
to live in a great city like New York or
London or Paris or LA you pretty much
have to have quite a lot of money
otherwise you're living three in an
apartment in it or in a really terrible
neighborhood and and so once you've got
that situation once it wants a dignified
life on relatively small amounts of
money became impossible and the
possibility existed to make money if you
join the kind of nexus of advertising
and the media the commercial media well
then it's hardly humanly surprising that
people went in that direction
see I didn't those issues maybe that's
just the vulgar materialist in me but I
think those issues are much were
critical crucial apartment to what
happened over the last thirty years then
some sort of you know shift in the
zeitgeist do do I don't know you know
people's characters or whatever I mean
that strikes me as as as more essential
also money you know this silly season of
Wall Street which we've now which has
now ended George Soros said in an
interview the other day and I think The
Times of London that you know we're
never going back to the world over the
last twenty five years it's not I mean
of course there'll be an end to this
recession or depression or whatever we
want to call it but the idea that you
know we're going back to a world where
markets only went up where people you
know seem to have more disposable income
every year where credit was
promiscuously granted and promiscuously
used that's over he said and I you know
that means that culture where someone
who does video art or writes novels can
seriously imagine that she she or he
will also have the income of a what we
used to call a very rich person what now
would just be called the middle-class
person that's finished
that's over so I don't know I mean I'm
so sure that my mother's way of being
may not be more emblematic of the future
than it was maybe of the last part of
her own
you